mille présentoirs de gel hydroalcoolique
fabriqué en huit jours voilà le bilan
provisoire de la nouvelle stratégie de
deux les âges spécialisée dans la
fabrication de mobilier d'événementiel
cette entreprise s'est réinventé des
produits destinés à la préparation du
déconfinement pour les entreprises
notamment avec ses écrans de protection
en plexiglas pour les bureaux sur des
grandes plaques en trois parts de on
peut découper pas mal de pause avec des
systèmes de pied très très simple à
utiliser qui protège vraiment tous les
bureaux toutes les personnes dans des
accueils etc
techniquement il ya rien de nouveau
c'est juste des adaptations de forme
pour pouvoir créer en fait des produits
comme vous avez vu tout à l'heure
s'adapter aux besoins dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire le choix opéré par la
dirigeante de cette société virginie
deneux ville les premiers produits ont
été pensés dès le début du confinement
je me suis vraiment on fait une
réflexion sur les besoins calais à voir
les gens en sortent et confinement c'est
un besoin physique et psychologique
physique parce qu'il faut se battre
contre un virus
les psychologique parce que si vous
voulez que les salariés les
collaborateurs soit dans un état serein
pour reprendre leur travail
il faut leur montrer dans l'entreprise
qu'on met tout en oeuvre pour qu il y
ait zéro risque des cloisons de
séparation entre les bureaux des écrans
de protection pour les restaurants ou
les comptoirs d'accueil plusieurs gammes
ont été conçus avec une cinquantaine de
commandes programmer la production a
redémarré mi avril
chaque gamme va me permettre de
travailler soit aussi bien avec un appel
d'offres public une salle de conférence
à un gros centre de conférences comme on
le fait d'habitude a par exemple lancé
des oeufs ou des clients comme ça ou de
senna ucia que les commerçants ou le
restaurateur du coin avec un tiers du
chiffre d'affaires réalisé au mois de
mars cette nouvelle activité doit
permettre d'amortir cette perte
en attendant une reprise de l'activité
habituelle dans le secteur de
l'événementiel